a vitro you found it prep me in 2001
sold it ten years later in 2011 that was
actually the year we found it imagine
k12 the world's first educational
technology accelerator and and Keith you
founded mystery science I think in 2013
we just celebrated our fourth birthday
in January and you just celebrate your
fourth birthday with with with Doug
pelts and you guys actually did YC in
summer 2017 so this the idea of this
podcast was to have a conversation about
educational technology about maybe some
some current past and future stories
around our on ed tech one of the things
that that started the that was the
initiative for this conversation was a
blog post that a VTL wrote in 2011
titled why educational startups do not
succeed his summary of that post I'll
just I'll just give it really quickly
since he helpfully put it in the post
itself was that that entrepreneurs and
education built a wrong kind of business
they think of it as a quality problem
when actually it's a cost problem
building an education does not follow an
Internet company's growth curve and
because of that it's you have to think
way longer term than venture capitalists
are interested in funding you so the
opportunities for servicing education
they're actually not in the u.s. they're
actually in Asia so so like it's not
really gonna be relevant for another
five years
that was in 2011 so maybe it's relevant
now because that would have led us to
2016 maybe eventually you can start by
sort of reflecting on why you wrote that
post and and how you're thinking about
it today and then and hopefully you guys
can start having a conversation about
that yeah I think it's great that's a
great summary that's a great intro I
mean I the the genesis of that blog post
for us was really we started this
company we had a lot of ideas around how
to make education better using machine
learning and using technology and
personalization and it turned out a lot
of
a lot of people wanted that in the early
days and so we got some early signal
that that's that's actually what the
market wanted and then very quickly
things started to plateau from a growth
perspective and I think my conclusion
was that we'd saturated a lot of the
early adopters and the mainstream market
just wanted different things the
mainstream market really cared much more
about cost rather than quality and the
the fundamental sort of disconnect
between people who start education
businesses and the consumer themselves
is fundamentally that the people who
start education businesses tend to care
much much more about the quality of the
product and in the u.s. the average
consumer just looks at it differently in
the buying psychology is fundamentally
different in there they're a whole host
of reasons why that's the case that we
can get into that I think I actually
have very interesting downstream
ramifications on things like politics
about whether people value education
yeah any self yeah exactly and I mean
actually so if we want to sort of unpack
that the the the thing I think and this
is I have very little other than
anecdotal to back this up so this is my
current belief if I could be wrong who
love to hear probably from Keith why I'm
wrong but I think what happened was
post-world War two America was really
good for for a lot of people as I grew
up in Ohio and Kentucky and so you know
if you're in the 60s or the 70s you
could get a job at the GM factory you
could make a good wage your spouse could
make a good wage so maybe together you
make eighty thousand dollars a year
working the factory and a house cost
eighty thousand dollars a year
all right so that'd be like living in
San Francisco and you and your spouse
make like three million dollars a year
and you never went to college I think
you would rationally you would look at
that and be like well why would I go to
college I'm making three million dollars
a year
I ain't buy my house and I can have a
great life and and then the people that
were sort of born let's just to make the
math easy let's say you were born in
1982 so you'd be 18 in the year 2000
you'd be graduating from high school the
people were born in 1982 were raised by
people of that generation and so kind of
the value system sort of I think came
from a belief that the world would still
work that way but the world doesn't
actually work that way right like
starting with 2000 you know the internet
with the crash in 2001 the massive you
know there was in between little
recession
a crash in 2008 so basically if you were
an adult in 2000 you've you've kind of
been in and out of work for most serial
life if you were kind of in that camp if
you didn't go to college and and that
that kind of I think has bleed-over
effects into into things like politics
where like the system the way you
thought the world was going to work the
world doesn't actually work that way
anymore and that disconnect has been a
really hard transition and there's this
entire sort of you know 15 to 20 year
range of adults it kind of got trapped
by it and I think we're seeing some of
the effects of that right now in
politics Keith maybe maybe you can react
to that I'm especially interested in in
this perspective that I think was more
true in 2001 than it is in 2018 which is
that if you're gonna make any money in
educational technology you better appeal
directly to parents and because schools
weren't gonna pay for technology
actually they'd been burned with a whole
bunch of hardware and technology wasn't
so relevant to them at the time that
seems like it shifted a bit so maybe you
can yeah I mean one one interesting
thing when talking about the space is
it's it's I think it's actually hard to
talk about the education space like
elementary versus high school are
totally different markets in many
respects and parents verse verse
institutions are very different markets
so it's interesting you know we often
sort of group this as the education
space or the education industry and and
we have to be careful about generalizing
um and so I mean just one Lineman
Mystery Science we are helping fix
science education in this country by
giving elementary teachers a remote
science expert to co teach the class
with them so we effectively sell schools
a curriculum that that replaces the
textbook you could think of it in a
sense as a digital textbook in our whole
pitch to to teachers and to schools is
that this is better this is better
education it's better than the textbooks
it's better than whatever the
conventional curriculum is and it's
notable that that our teachers and the
students and even parents increasingly
are starting to recognize that it's
better so so it you know it does give me
pause to hear you know you can't build a
business by making something better I
think there are some interesting
challenges to to trying to
how you communicate that your product is
better and how the customers appreciate
it but yep you know so for just very
early on where we've gotten a lot of
traction selling into schools and and
getting appreciated for making a better
educational product it does seem to be
true to back up of each house point
about about parents in general not being
willing to pay especially sort of the
the mass-market to be willing to pay for
education quality they're the the value
that they place on that in the United
States at least is still not clear that
there's a lot of money being spent
outside of school and education but it's
test prep and tutoring for pretty
affluent families isn't that true yeah
it's it is it isn't interesting so we
are preparing for a transition from
selling to schools selling direct to
parents and so we've sort of dipped our
toe in the water with home schoolers
which is a relatively small market and
are getting ready to go mainstream and
so there's still a lot yet for us to
prove about that but there's a couple
interesting observations that we've made
so far I think the thing that makes the
market a funny market that the parent
education market is that you get this
product for free so you know basically
through property taxes that's how you
pay for school but you know as an
entrepreneur or trying to build a
business in the space that's interesting
to compete with free out there because
parents feel like well I have this thing
and so one thing we've noticed in
interviewing parents is that at the very
young age parents feel very involved in
learning so you know from birth to when
they send their kid off to kindergarten
or preschool the the educational value
of the products they're buying is is one
of the dominant factors and considering
whether you're going to buy that
speaking sound or that play mat or that
book or or whatnot it's a huge factor in
buying decisions once you send your kid
off to school full time parents remain
involved in some respects I think
reading is one of the main ones they
still think feel like it's their job to
make sure they're reading regularly to
their child and and helping to reinforce
you know their ability to read at home
and then it sort of drops off for the
next like six to eight years your
involvement on a parent
as a parent in education is making sure
you're supporting the school and going
to parent-teacher conference and you
know picking the right neighborhood or
you sort of you get involved in that
respect not by buying products and sort
of delivering education at home and then
towards the end of high school it kind
of ramps up again with the whole like
getting into college thing or shoring up
a weak grade or whatnot yeah well it
certainly seems that that your
prediction that venture capitalists
wouldn't fund EdTech companies has not
come true especially since 2011 and I
was very interesting we found it imagine
k12 in 2011 and the companies that we
found it along received hundreds of
millions of dollars in venture
investment so obviously venture
capitalists saw opportunity somewhere
actor right yeah I think I think they
basically made the mistake that I that I
tried to call out in that post which is
I think they they expected that the ramp
of those companies from from a business
perspective would look like an Internet
company ramp
whereas I think I mean I don't know the
numbers and most of the American
companies but I think they pale in
comparison to like Chinese education
companies that go from like zero to a
billion you know an IPO in seven years
it's just like the ramps are just crazy
and it's always like China and on the
more people in China I mean that's
that's part of it right and and and the
public school system is much worse
exactly right I think the cultural
dynamics are different the public school
dynamics are different there are there a
lot of factors there for sure but but
the net effect of it then ends up being
on paper you might have a company here
as an education company that's worth a
hundred million dollars or two hundred
million dollars and has raised a lot of
venture capital but to the revenue
numbers actually back that up all right
could you actually take that public on
the market in two to three years at a
billion dollar valuation and what kind
of revenue would you have to do to
support that and I think by and large
that hasn't been the case which is why
you haven't really seen education
company IPOs but is that unique to
education companies because just take
consumer tech generally yeah there's
many hundred million dollar-plus
valuation consumer tech companies yeah
that don't have the revenue to back it
up yeah and there are also many consumer
tech companies in China where the
Chinese equivalent will scale much
faster than the American equivalent yeah
the the reason I so it's certainly true
that I think you have a lot of companies
that are
that end up in this kind of dead zone
but the reason they do is because there
are some that make it out like every now
and then you'll get a snapchat or a
whatsapp or an uber or a lift or a
stripe or like the list goes on right
like in most these companies are not
that old right like these are all seven
to eight year old companies right so
it's it's the hope that you stumble into
an uber or a stripe that really I think
supports the the rest of the ecosystem
right but I don't see like where is the
uber or the stripe of the education
space yeah yeah the closest is probably
you know ABC Mouse instant
billion-dollar valuation straight to
parents yeah and teachers pay teachers
would be another one yeah hey you know
jug is worth to a nap show you know
that's actually a great example that's
actually the one that I use most often
which is by and large if you look at
check the way they got to where they are
is they didn't reinvent digital learning
they just made textbooks cheaper yeah
but they've come they've almost
completely shifted if you look at if you
look at chegs website today yeah they
don't talk about textbooks anymore it's
there there there there are smarter way
to student turn whatever that means
yeah so so that you know but I think
it's all about digital education for
technology and you know I know it's a
multi hundred million dollar business
for them I was gonna ask you know do you
know what their number how that number
breaks down between like their core
textbook business versus I think the
core textbook business and volume is
bigger but the digital business is is
rapidly growing on scaling so it's
interesting there there there are there
are tech companies that are scaling
certainly revenue has been tough yeah
for many of them although you know I
look at companies like Mystery Science
which is actually scaled revenue without
mentioning any numbers very well by
selling to schools
I do think selling to parents still
because of this this free zone it and we
have to be clear that for better or
worse that free zone is is for the mass
market middle America there is plenty of
more affluent families that spend tens
of thousands of dollars over a year on
private schools on private tutors on an
SAT prep on all sorts of educational
advantages that
that do constitute a pretty big market
right yeah yeah and it's notable that
ABC Mouse is in some ways I think of
them as the new leapfrog like they're
targeting that same age demographic that
leapfrog used to which is outside of
that free zone yeah it's the early state
like the early yep yeah yeah I think
that I mean that pattern is held for a
while too that's why I mean in that blog
post I called out something like five
years because I think what you're
starting to see is cultural shifts just
take a while right and I do think there
is a cultural shift and the cultural
shift essentially is that generation of
parents that were 18 in the year 2000 or
you know their parents now and they have
five-year-olds right there so the person
that was 18 in the year 2000 be 36 today
so I probably you know they might have
some young kids and I think they're
starting to look back at you know they
probably don't have a 25 year old but
they might have a 6 year older and 8
year old so starting to look back at
their life and saying wait a second like
what happened over the world changed and
so I think people are generally pretty
smart and so they're started that
cultural change is starting to happen or
that might be the 36 year old that's now
the head of the science department and
is looking at it and saying wait a
second I grew up with the Internet like
I get this we should be better buying
better stuff and so I do think that
change is happening but we're kind of at
like the early parts of that change and
hopefully it accelerates but I don't
think we're like I don't think the
mainstream is like flipped quite yet
there's another aspect of the cultural
change which seems to me is a cultural
change within schools which for me has
shifted radically you know in 2011 when
you wrote that post the fact is that
most schools were not connected with
reasonable internet access today almost
all of them the United States are
connected with the hot you know enough
bandwidth for more than one person
because we're not too bit the same at
the same time many schools of directors
of Technology and are thinking about
their their technology buying plan so it
seems to me I don't know how you think
about yeah I think that's in the school
space I think that's one of the most
significant things is it's from my
perspective it seems like it is
mirroring the enterprise cycle lagging
about 10 years or so so when we started
four years ago we finally could assume
that most of our teachers would have a
computer and a
one computer in the classroom a
projector so the kids could see it in an
internet connection not the best
internet connection often consumer-grade
shared it would slow down during lunch
hour and then speed up afterwards but we
could assume this baseline level and
that was 2014 you know so maybe that
only happened around 2012 or so like
that's that's relatively late compared
to what happened in business and so you
know I think we are we are you know
really deep into this first generation
cycle where there's a whole wave of
companies that that are just bringing
efficiency to schools so it's like hey
now that we're on the Internet we can
make attendance easier we can make
grading easier we can make student
rostering easier we can make you know a
lot of back office stuff and so that's a
whole wave of companies that aren't even
involved in learning they're just
involved in making these business
operations more efficient because hey
internets you software is good for that
and then there's the second parallel
we're seeing and this was was part of
the wave we're riding in other companies
where it used to be that there were
directors of technology in business who
made this software purchasing decision
and then rolled out to everyone and said
you know that's how the school director
of technology started and now you know
we take the Salesforce sales model to
these teachers where Salesforce didn't
get permission from an IT department
they just got someone in marketing who
signed up for a free account and got
started and then three or four or five
more people got it and eventually the IT
department had to take notice because
they had 50 users in the company and so
so we do the same thing with our
software and in other EdTech companies
too I don't think we pioneered this yeah
this what pull model instead of the push
model instead of having to wine and dine
supervisors around the country you
actually convince persuade teachers that
you have a great product and in the end
they persuade their administrators to
buy yep yep and there's a bunch of
interesting shifts that happened there
so you know Salesforce was selling
against incumbent CRM providers like I
used to more Oracle had a product like
that and their product looks different
like the onboarding for it looks
different and the in the cost structure
looks different and we're seeing that
same shift we've got the Pearson
mcgraw-hill mifflin that generation of
companies who still assume they're gonna
sell top-down and rollout right and then
Mystery Science and other tech companies
that that just do the ala carte enroll
so a veto do you think do you think your
conclusions still stand today however
you modified your take given what's
happened over the past I mean sort of
gave it five years and it's been seven
would you let me let me just read your
conclusions and and I'm wondering if you
think they're still valid today or
whether you would you would counsel new
ed tech entrepreneurs differently this
is the good bad of things and to be fair
I disagree with very little of what he
wrote in in 2001 right and so the real
question is have have we moved on and if
so how should we move on yeah so your
your first point was don't make a better
product make a cheaper product yeah
which by the way the sufficiency stuff
that he's talking about
please directly to that yeah don't start
in the u.s. start in or other developed
countries because it'll be too slow
start in Asia
don't take VC money don't target the
middle class because they don't really
care and don't expect a quick flip yeah
or quick growth you wanna you wanna you
know you can take those as a whole or
one a time however you like I think I
can take them as a whole I think they're
generally still true but there are
pockets where it's starting to change
and I think the places were you're
starting to see a change are especially
around I think schools have changed a
lot I think things like I was I was
talking to Dan and clever and he was
talking about how Chromebooks have just
changed the landscape dan the CTO
correct thank you all the CTO becomes
also is clubber YC yeah clever is a YC
yeah should be an Imagine k12 long story
for another time so he was making the
really great observation that that to
your point too I think is that just
changes the game all of a sudden you can
actually assume that there's there's an
internet connection and a thing that
looks like a laptop and it's pretty
reasonable and has good specs so I think
kind of like the the fundamentals have
the fundamentals have changed but the
way that the fundamentals then manifest
in terms of startups is just starting to
change because there's a phase shift
there so now that Internet is good now
that the person making the decisions
might be the department head or the
teacher now that there are
that you can just sign up for and you
don't need to go through the district
like all those are structural changes
that have just started to happen in the
last you know let's say two years three
years that that's really gone mainstream
so I think looking forward now so I
think the question really is like are
they still true today take a snapshot I
think the answer is mostly still true
but that's not really the question that
that like a startups should be asking
our founders should be asking is like
will it be true in five years I don't
think it will be true in five years
right like if you're starting a company
today the question really is are there
enough customers for you to get going
and has the world of all such that in
five years it will be dramatically
different and look a lot more like your
early adopters and I think it will well
they're all forward-looking statements
so I think you're basically saying
ignore that blog post because the future
the future is different the future looks
I think really bad our friend I think
the future looks a lot better the feet
of the the present as of today still
kind of looks like that but the trend
lines are good right and so you look at
mystery science you look at no red ink
or you look at clever they're all these
companies that I think have managed to
get pretty substantial traction and so
if you're starting today I think some of
these markets are actually you can't get
quickly you can get nor any reasonable
growth pretty quickly I think the part
of it that's still hard is actually the
monetization and and I think that part
of it is just gonna be phase shift and I
think that will come and so it's it kind
of is a case-by-case basis I think in
the early early parts of the market kind
of what Keith was saying if you if
you're targeting four-year-olds and
five-year-olds and six-year-olds you
might actually be able to make a lot of
progress and actually monetize because
the the buying psychology I think has
changed if you're talking about 14-year
olds you might not be able to write and
so it kind of depends on the market that
you're going after I still think that
Asia thing is 100% true like I think if
you if you just look at the growth of
companies and the revenue in those
markets I think China is just an amazing
amazing market and so unfortunately it's
not most people are not faced with the
decision which should I start a company
in the US or should I start a company in
China it's like it's one or the other
it's difficult in the u.s. to go yeah
Persis French and vice versa don't know
the markets and vice versa yeah and so
that's not really for most people a
decision point I think the more
important decision point for most most
entrepreneurs probably is like which
part of the market am I going after
wine is it as higher-ed is a you know
night you know high school is it science
education is at math education is it
pre-k there are a lot of ways to segment
the market and so I think some of those
have moved much more than others and the
trajectory looks really good so I think
they're going to be pockets a pretty
substantial change in the next five
years and some of the I think we'll just
take a while longer like I actually
think high schools will take a bit
longer than some of these others just
because the phase shift right like the
parents you kind of have to have the
market grow into it keek maybe we can
talk a little bit about of each house
original first point which was the
precise opposite of what you guys did
later right which is not don't build a
better product build a cheaper product
you guys in fact did Bill didn't build a
mass with the expensive product but you
built a better product what you you're a
whole idea was to build better science
education and I think this is an
interesting conversation because the
real issue an American education isn't
price it's quality it's how can we get
better outcomes maybe you can reflect a
little bit on yeah I mean I'm that
opportunity yeah so I definitely think
there's opportunity to build a better
product in the education space I think I
think right now that's that's absolutely
true and I think it's I think it was
true four years ago even when we started
that you could build a better product
and I think to the extent that the
advice is useful of don't build a better
product build a cheaper one it's not
unique for the education space like
there are many many startups whose
growth is driven by lowering cost you
know I mean that the whole media space
like like the news media space online is
being driven by free newspapers instead
of you know print newspapers and lots of
people argue oh my gosh consumers don't
care about the quality of reporting
anymore all they care about is something
that's free and it's you know I think
it's true that free is a really
important driver in every industry or
lowering cost as an important driver in
every industry and that's not unique to
education but but the conclusion that
the consumer doesn't care about quality
I think is it it's one I'm very hesitant
to make because oftentimes we as the
creator have a unique set of things that
we think are important and then we imbue
that in a product and if it doesn't
resonate
people in the same way you know it's
often have you have to charge a little
bit more than it's easy to think oh they
just don't care about quality like I
could imagine you know in the furniture
space just to pick a totally different
industry you know one of the high-end
designer furniture stores for many years
was Design Within Reach
never actually shopped there but I
walked in one and they said like $20,000
couches that's probably like the low-end
couch there you know and you can imagine
this the whole fine furniture industry
concluding the average consumer they
don't care about design like they just
want cheap stuff and then IKEA comes
along and brings design to the masses
and so do you think IKEA think so
consumers don't don't appreciate good
design it's like no they absolutely do
appreciate good design they're not gonna
pay twenty thousand dollars for for a
well-designed couch they'll but they'll
pay five hundred bucks for a
well-designed couch maybe even if that
was more of a balance for that sort of
consumer between yes consciousness and
quality yeah so I don't think there's
something unique about the education
space that the you know to conclude
consumers don't appreciate this I think
that you you create more value you price
it right and you play that you have to
figure out the market dynamics to scale
but what consumers you know customers
appreciate it in our case we started out
focusing on teachers and you know with
the challenging thing in education and
this is also true of other industries is
how does the consumer know what's better
how does the customer know what's better
in teachers well you know our particular
customers they don't have a lot of
strong opinions about you know a better
science resource would have the
following attributes like so they're not
searching for better necessarily at
least with a clear set of guidelines but
when they see it they can recognize it
and we hear all sorts of feedback from
teachers like wow I've never seen it's a
lesson taught this way before I don't
know what it is about it there's just
something different and you can see it
in their testimonials that they're sort
of they're groping at their own
identification of what it is so they can
tell it even though they can't put their
finger on it you know and you can
imagine a consumer like you make a
healthier you know granola bar and and
you know the average consumer doesn't
know what is the right balance of
nutrients to make something healthier
but the they could notice how they feel
in the long run by by changing their
diet I think that's actually a good
example I yeah I mostly disagree with
what you just said
let me I'll give examples right Tesla
started at the high end right and like
electric cars probably wouldn't happen
had Tesla not price it the way they did
and there's like a bunch of work that
they had to do to come down the iPhone
kind of worked that way like a lot of
Technology cycles I think actually work
with things that are more expensive that
are smaller and niche and then they
would come down in price over time
because often there is a trade-off
between quality and cost now in like
content creation I think you could argue
that the tooling has gotten so much
better that the cost of production has
come down dramatically and therefore you
don't really have the same trade-offs
that you use to and so I think with
mystery sense is a great example right
like software toolings gotten so good
that you guys can have massive leverage
and create really high quality stuff and
and price of very competitively right
it's actually affordable for people but
it's really really high quality but a
lot of things don't have it is a
trade-off right and so to the extent
that you have to make the trade-off I
think that's actually where things get
hard is like the average person is going
to make likely a different trade-off
than the person building the product and
that's kind of where I think companies
end up making the wrong trade-off is
like the person building the product
says clearly if it cost ten percent more
but is 20 percent better or 30 percent
better I should that's a worthwhile
trade-off and that's actually not the
buying psychology the consumer and
that's where I think on the margin
things like get harder well do you think
but do you think that's unique to
education like most consumer products I
think it's unique to certain certain
things and I think the characteristic of
Education that makes it there - there
are two parts of education which is kind
of like healthcare that I think make it
really hard one is the long ROI cycle or
it's just like it pays off in 20 years
and us like humans are just bad at that
right we were that's why health care I
think has some of these challenges and
the other is I think your point which is
how do I know it's better right like
what do you what tells me that it's
better if the payoff cycle is 20 years
or granola right like better food for
your nutrition is a great example right
people make all sorts of suboptimal
decisions in the short term when it's
clear what the right long term decisions
are and most people just don't make the
right long-term trade-off and I think
it's it's exactly this it's like the
payoff is really really long and
evaluating quality in the short term is
really tough you wouldn't really argue
that people don't make quality
trade-offs though for food
they sure do there might be wrong and
they might be a little opaque but they
sure do make those trade-offs all the
time and I think that's probably true in
education as well and health care how do
you
well people think certain granolas are
better than other granolas and think
people certain berries are better than
other Tories and think like there's pay
the money for organic for example
because they believe and of course
there's because and part of that is that
there are there are shorthand for what
quality tastes like so you know a
mystery science lesson tastes better
than then a dry textbook without dugs
actually doing it so so maybe maybe
there are ways for people to signal
quality and to believe in quality I look
at kind of as like you know the the way
that I think like the way that we would
evaluate quality here I think like
making it fun and accessible absolutely
part of quality but fundamentally it's
about driving educational outcomes right
like if you didn't learn the thing
better is it actually better quality I
argue if you didn't actually learn the
thing like it's not a better quality
need short hands because because the
ultimate educational outcome which means
you get a better job it's more
satisfying higher paying etc yeah is too
long a cycle yeah what schools use and
parents by default then uses test
results yeah that's right I guess those
are the outcomes that that we have to
use as a shorthand yeah I think I think
this is more I will argue that this is
more of a symptom of a Mis measurement
of a better education so since so much
of a man about the way that people
evaluate whether a product is a better
educational product is very often with
some internal set of standards and
heuristic that that a district will use
for purchasing or it's a standardized
assessment that they're gonna measure at
the end of fifth grade and eighth grade
or whatnot
I personally questioned whether those
are actually proxies for quality at all
yeah and meanwhile the thing that they
ignore which I think is the right proxy
is what's the level of student
engagement like our students excited and
and eager to to take the next step in
that lesson or or to to understand this
concept and that's largely ignored by
most people designing educational
products because they're striving for
some Platonic ideal of raising a
standardized assessment and and they're
just they're just missing it and so when
you when you understand that
motivation is central to learning you I
mean one of our internal principles you
can't teach a child something that they
don't care to understand like if they
don't want to understand it no amount of
trying to shove it down their throat
will lead to any kind of learning
outcome whatsoever
and so when when you understand that
when you see motivation as essential to
learning you get an immediate feedback
loop and students students respond right
away you can tell whether they're
learning students want more of this and
so I think that this idea that there's a
long cycle to measuring improvement is
is one of the sort of legacies of the
educational system that we're still
working to shed because we lack a real
measure of learning up yeah how percent
agree that I mean I think a huge part of
it is a side effect of the way that we
do the measurements and and therefore
like the way that we measure quality
quote-unquote ends up skewing in a very
particular way which has all sorts of
downstream and I think I think the the
the disconnect that people feel between
well I've made a product which is better
according to this mistaken measure of
quality but gosh it's just not working
in the market like I'm not getting in
the reception it's not that the market
doesn't value quality question the
assumption it's maybe maybe what I
thought was an indication of better
quality is really not an indication of
better quality the um just to advance
that conversation a little bit something
that I struggle with a lot is that the
educational system that were stuck with
today was building children building
outcomes for a world that doesn't really
exist anymore
yeah the world has changed so much and I
think one of the issues we have with
measuring quality is for what I think
there's a lot of questions being posed
as to what the value of an education
actually is in in an actual long-term
outcomes for children how should we even
think of that and how would one advise
an EdTech company who's trying to build
some Platonic ideal in that world for
what to do it's a great question I think
I think you're basically I mean the that
is the core of the problem right is like
what are we actually building the
educational system for and towards what
end and I think I don't think there's a
great answer right now honestly and I
think it's as much a public policy
question as it is a technology question
like what are we actually trying to
optimize for and I think all that people
are for what it's worth I think what's
starting to happen is people are
starting to at least realize that it's
broken and so I think that whole
generation of people that sort of went
through that system and ended up kind of
you know misaligned for the skills that
you actually need in the job market
today are realizing that system is
broken but I don't think there's like a
there's not a cohesive plan that I've
seen that says like here's how to
actually fix it and so I wish I knew the
answer that personally but I don't think
there's actually like I don't think
there I haven't really seen a great
solution to it other than sort of very
point wise oh we should have more STEM
education or we should you know get
programming and earlier you know schools
or I think there's sort of these like
point-wise solutions that are very
tactical but there isn't like a cohesive
strategy that I've seen yeah program is
an interesting one sorry Keith you
wanted to say something good I think you
you absolutely have to have an opinion
on that fundamental question if you are
building an education company you have
to have an opinion on what is the
purpose of Education because if it's to
create more of a certain kind of
professional because of a career
shortage that will lead to a whole set
of decisions in an assessment of
progress or if it's you know GDP growth
or know there's many yeah I think
mistaken views of what the purpose of
education is and in the fact that that
as a culture we don't have alignment on
that you know that speaks to to this
system that's being pulled in so many
different directions yeah I mean I mean
we we hold a very strong unconventional
view on it and it's that the ultimate
purpose of Education is that children
grow up and live happy and productive
lives and even taking something like
science like I think it is an absolute
mistake to say that we should teach
children more science because there's a
lot of STEM careers out there that that
that need to be filled like that's
absolutely the mistaken approach and
many people hold that view
why didn't at least leads towards a
bunch of wrong decisions why do you
think Michigan um it's a great it's a
great long conversation we're trying to
convince it but I'll give you a data
point which will speak to it
yeah I think if there was a young child
who knew that he or she wanted to be a
dancer
that's the profession they knew they
wanted to be and there was no chance
that they wanted to pursue a stem career
they should that child too should learn
science it's not that they should learn
science because of a particular career
outcome because the implication of that
is once I decide that's not the career
then like forget this I don't need this
this knowledge anymore
there's I think there is a fundamental
baseline understanding of the world that
you're surrounded by the way it works
and a the habits of thinking that you
form by figuring out how the world works
and so science is this body of knowledge
this core knowledge about how the world
works and it's a methodology in
discovering these truths about the world
and every child should learn that
because it will enable them to be a
happier and more successful dancer just
as it will a happier and more successful
programmer so where do you think that
bounds of that kind of end is it like
computer science and programming is it
math is it you know writing skills is it
absolutely the right question and it is
the harder question to answer which is
so what does a core fundamental
pedagogical you know a pedagogy and
curriculum consists of in order to
maximize for as many children as
possible growing up and living happy and
productive lives like I that's there's a
lot of healthy debate that should be
happening there I wish that was the
debate that was happening I wish there
was agreement on the outcome and the
purpose of this all because that would
be having the right to Scott not you
know the industry would be having the
right discussion I love that that you
make the point that people can live
happier more fulfilled lives by knowing
science I'm not sure that there's a lot
of evidence to to back that up but I
would like to make an appointment on on
the social case for certain kinds of
education because because what certain
types of education does bring to kids is
critical thinking and the ability to ask
hard questions and think skeptically
about about the world which
seems relevant today for all sorts of
reasons wouldn't isn't even a more
powerful argument is that when we're
we're educating our our kids to be
productive citizens of the 21st century
and without an understanding of the
scientific method and what science
implies for everything huh as an example
there's more right how can you be that
productive citizen what do you guys
think yeah I mean I think that's hard to
argue with I think critical thinking
skills you know science math I would
argue actually programming just as a
framework to think logically and clearly
about the world writing I think the
ability to communicate effectively I
think these are all just foundational
skills regardless of what you end up end
up doing so no argument for me on that I
think the hard part is can you be happy
and productive if you don't have a job
like just to bring it back to earth a
little bit is like if I can't feed my
family am I going to be happy and
productive and that's I think kind of
like where the boundaries are is like to
what separate wouldn't you argue as well
that if you think clearly and you have
great communication skills you're better
positioned to get a job in in in the
world that's being created all around us
than otherwise maybe I mean to think so
I'd like to think so as somebody who
yeah loves reading philosophy in science
fiction and you know loves music and all
these things I would like to think so
but you know like I think I think the
edge cases are kind of the interesting
ones like you know if you have an
English degree and you know there's a
gross understatement ists like that
feels like a like could that person
learn how to do Python and sequel and
like go get that job absolutely they're
smart they could certainly do that but
like that is that like a missed
opportunity is that person now like in
an awkward place having taken $100,000
in debt when they probably should have
just like done you know could have done
something else not probably with me and
those like pound recondition Zhai think
are the tough part but I think you have
to be really careful with the the
societal argument you know and so there
is a subtle switch where you're saying
but what about the societal this is good
for all of us if people learn these
skills and I agree with your Restatement
of it it is you're right it is good for
every one of those individuals to learn
those skills because it
helped them but it but I don't think we
can justify this on the grounds of but
it's good for society and I'll give you
an example like my wife was with someone
who was in it you know ap math and in
science classes in high school and as a
woman who was good at math she got a lot
of pressure to to join the math team and
be that the female math representative
for the school and and it was really
hard for her for a while because her
passion was history and the social
sciences but there was lots of pressure
because it would be good for society to
have more female representation and she
struggled with that for a little while
ultimately she pursued the things that
made her more happy and fulfilled not
the thing that other people felt would
be good for society because of some
metrics that we need to hit and I think
that as soon as you holds a societal
standard you you very quickly start to
make decisions which will be at odds
with what any one individual would want
for themselves because it's it's best
for society yeah and I think like
probably not a little bit more to me the
hardest trade-offs are actually for the
individual in those sort of like edge
case situations like it's an interesting
example like if if your passion is in
one direction and you could go really
deep on that but all the jobs are in the
other direction like setting aside some
baseline level of scientific method and
math and you're you're going to a good
college like so that's kind of an
interesting and hard individual
trade-off and that I think starts to get
at actually like what what is the
purpose and what are you optimizing for
as a system because I think in a lot of
those cases it I think there are you
know you can look at let's say
unemployment rates where people who have
a college degree and it's it's actually
relatively low or it's below 5% and it's
really like whether or not you have that
college degree that changes whether or
not you're employed but there are a lot
of nuances to that there's
underemployment there's having and what
kind of salary growth potential do you
have and and I I think and I think I
take a little bit more of a pragmatic
approach of like probably more people
should be getting computer science
degrees and like learning data science
and that's like if better if more people
want to be getting a computer science
degree but it's a it's a critical and
important part of being happy and
fulfilled that you have a like job that
pays you well and you can like feed your
family and you feel
Tribble I'm like that's a that's an
important part above and beyond like
your it's a whole separate conversation
whether you believe that having a job is
a critical part of happiness because and
it's easy for those of us who have the
sorts of jobs that frankly the people in
this room have where they're you know
were the opposite of wage slaves word
which is what most people are and so
that's a different conversation but it
is interesting to talk about the the
societal goals of Education to I mean
education public education a nine states
was a was was for the benefit of society
as opposed to individuals who I don't
think people really knew that that that
getting people ready to to be good
factory workers was good for them it was
more about we need factory workers so we
better educate them sufficiently so they
can they can be good let's let's bring
the conversation back to education
technology my hope is that educational
technology helps both individuals at
society achieve outcomes that that that
we we in this room and in the country
would be happy with what do you guys
today recommend when you meet an EdTech
founder I suspect you probably say
different things maybe you can each in
turn say like if someone tells you about
they're a tech startup it's a hard
general question to answer but where do
you guys sort of go with your advice do
you do you I'll start with you have a
child you do you sort of channel your
2011 self or do you do talk about sort
of how the world's changing and the
opportunities that are thus created yeah
I try to channel Keith a little bit and
I asked them what their motivations
alright and try to do what's good for
the individual exceda I don't think
there's a right answer right there are a
lot of reasons that people might want to
start an education company and so I
think the foundational thing is really
what is your motivation and why are you
doing it and and I think especially in
Silicon Valley there's too much of a
lens of well if it's not a billion
dollar outcome if it's not a ten billion
dollar exit it doesn't matter and there
are lots of motivations that people may
have and so the first step I think is
what is your motivation and there
lots of great businesses that people
should start and could start that have
very very meaningful impact on people's
lives and in their communities and
they'll be fifty million dollar
businesses or hundred million dollar
businesses and that's fantastic like
people should go do those things but if
that's if that's kind of the zone that
you're in and that's your motivation and
that's what you want to do then then it
comes down to well what are the right
tactics to executing on that and how do
you stay really smart about it because
the worst possible scenario would be you
had this great thing it was actually
working but for example tactically just
ended up raising money in the wrong way
and and now you've kind of gutted your
company because you don't actually
control it you have these options or
mispriced nobody can actually make money
by being at your company so you your all
your best people leave again under this
bad death spiral if you like greet your
company in the wrong way so I think the
fundamental thing is what is your
motivation why do you want to do it okay
let's figure out what the best way to
make that happen is and there are tons
and tons of great education and EdTech
businesses that are all in that spectrum
that's not too different than any other
startup any other story right in that
way that tactically then the the
specific thing that I say about
education is I try to get people to
really double down in their
understanding of what is the actual
thing that you want to accomplish like
you know you have your motivations and
then if you're successful a certain
thing will happen in the world and is
the path that you're on the best way to
necessarily make that thing happen in
the world are you better off for example
if you're if you're really into computer
science education there are lots of ways
to make that happen that are not
necessarily an education product right
are you actually better off trying to do
job retraining are you actually better
off doing it outside of school are you
better off doing it inside of school is
it actually at the high school level or
college level are you going to target
sub populace
there's so many ways to actually go
about making that happen that are sort
of adjacent to EdTech and so I think
this kind of gets out is like what is
EdTech exactly is an open question and
they're kind of like EdTech heavy and a
tech light and at tech adjacent yeah
we've really sort of skirted over the
fact that now that I actually Keith
mentioned in the beginning there's so
many aspects to attack you can slice and
dice in many ways from the home school
market to the elementary school market
to the to the high school then post
secondary market to-to-to training sorts
of markets yeah you know at YC be funded
lots of schools that train folks for
like inside data fellows
exam data Lam to school and people to be
to be programmers so there's there's
there it's a it's actually a pretty
broad field it seems like the
opportunity is only grown in it and in
what we're broadly calling it tech even
in the United States a gel completely
aside right yeah totally yeah and I
think those actually those things that
are a little bit more on the fringes to
me or are some of the most interesting
because they start to sort of redefine
what it means to get an education or
they redefine outside the bounds of this
sort of like public education you know
real estate funded tax funded sort of
model and start to start to explore what
it means to actually get an education
and stay educated and stay educated and
stay really and I think those kinds of
models are actually where there's a lot
of potential innovation because they're
free from a lot of the constraints that
exist in these models that have existed
for fifty or hundred years and that
freedom I think breeds a lot of
innovation i I agree with with most of
what of ATOL said particularly with
regards to giving some an advice on
picking a business they're gonna start
and most of my focus as well as on you
know what are you gonna be so excited to
work on that you're not going to give up
after two to three four years because
it's probably gonna take you ten years
so that you know that kind of heuristic
when you're picking a business is more
important than almost anything else but
specific to the education space I think
there's one the most contrarian thing
that I would share with someone is that
the education space you know I like to
say that we're a learning company not an
education company I'm very interested in
learning and how to improve learning and
when you think of yourself as a learning
company learning is a field that's
that's in its infancy right now and it's
it's deceptive because it's an old
industry so it feels like well we
figured all this out and you know that's
just like I don't know some efficiency
gains that are left and things like that
but to me learning is much more like
genetic engineering or you know in
figuring out how to arbitrarily sequence
DNA and inject it into an organ is like
the level of understanding we have about
that like we're still poking this black
box of genetic engineering and trying to
make stuff happen for the first time
that's the state of learning and and
fundamentally Wiest even though science
has progressed for so long
the science of the mind is so is still
at such a beginning you take a field
like physics and we know so much about
you know the farthest corners of the
universe and that the subatomic level
whereas our level of understanding of
psychology is is that this is that the
level of physics when it was well maybe
the guys are angry and they're shaking
the ground and that's why there's an
earthquake like we're still not that far
beyond Freud where it's like I don't
know maybe you went into this profession
because your parents had a particular
relationship with you and they steered
you in that direction it's it's it's
very much like opening a computer and
noticing that when you press this
sequence of buttons this part heats up
like that's our level of understanding
of the brain is like we we image this
thing and we notice where the blood
flows and try and draw these conclusions
about how it's working so if you anyone
who wants to start a company in the
learning space to the extent that you
that you really think focus on
understanding the science of learning
it's a wide open territory like we are
is actually it's still discovering
profound truths about even something as
simple as like space repetition and the
power of that or or the role of concept
formation and and what's the difference
between being able to recite a fact and
in that holding actually holding that
fact as knowledge like we're at the
beginning of a science and to the extent
you figure out anything new
there's there's huge business
implications of that are you optimistic
Keith that we'll figure it out and that
that will see a transformation in
American education over the next five 10
15 20 years that will actually make for
better outcomes for individuals and
society and and and then maybe a visual
if you could answer the same question
afterwards we can sort of close on on
that note
absolutely I mean I'm I will say I'm
long on the human race right so so we
are very good at figuring things out and
mastering sciences and then plumbing
them to new depths and we will do that
for learning and for pedagogy as we have
for all of the other sciences and you
know there is this industry in this
infrastructure this education
infrastructure that will crumble and go
away and be replaced by another verb
another version and what's so exciting
about the Internet is in you know the
internet generally in Mobile in
particular is these disruptive forces
give you these opportunities to rebuild
the whole stack from the ground up so
most likely the business opportunities
in the learning space will be outside of
the existing stack like it's the fact
that you can go straight to teachers and
not have to go through an approval
process is dramatically changing things
the fact that there's an internet in the
the cost structure fundamentally changes
and so it's a parent's - okay so the
science is wide open the industry is
gonna be transformed multiple times in
the next decade and and we will take
learning to the next level yeah I'm hard
to argue with not being optimistic about
the human race ya know I mean I guess
it's at least as entrepreneurs it's hard
you have to you have to be an optimist
right like you can't imagine you're
gonna change the world for the better if
you if you it's almost a definition yeah
you know what's impossible you're still
gonna get a couple that right so as an
entrepreneur I think it's hard to
separate that and so that my all of my
beliefs are tinged by that personality
trait but what I would say is I am very
optimistic about the experiments that
are happening by you know reaching
teachers in new ways reaching parents
and new ways platforms like the iPhone
or Android or iPad Chromebook that allow
people to interact with information and
novel and new and interesting ways and
things that are happening on the fringes
things that are that are education but
don't look like education I think
insight is a good example
I think people sort of exploring the
internet on their own and kind of going
down a rabbit hole of you know open
source or you know YouTube as a platform
with Khan Academy like I think they're
all these really interesting things
happening on the fringes where some of
them look like education some of them
look more like learning and some of them
look like job training and so they all
kind of have different flavors I'm less
optimistic about the sort of the
likelihood that we dramatically change
the state of public education in the
United States anytime soon because
there's just so many entrenched
components to that from funding
- you know the psychology that keith was
talking about we're like for the first
couple years it's really on the parent
and then there's a handoff there's so
many like cultural and governmental and
public policy things kind of rolled into
that I think unbundling that is going to
take a long time but I think there are a
lot of entrepreneurs kind of on the
fringes that are doing really
interesting things that and that's often
how disruption happens right it kind of
comes from the side a little bit and in
very unexpected ways and the timing can
surprise you so maybe we can leave on on
a slightly more optimistic note which is
that I think even in public education
public education we know a lot of what
the solutions ought to be so we're kind
of in a unique position where there's a
lot of structural reasons it's hard to
close the achievement gap and - and to
overall improve outcomes but we do know
a lot of the outcomes so since the
stakes couldn't be higher
I think that we have good reason to
believe that that those that knowledge
will eventually matter and that things
will get better I want to thank you both
for for podcasting with me this
afternoon it's been a great conversation
I've enjoyed it a lot thanks likewise
thanks
you